[Music]
you feel like your attitude towards
women has changed since having daughters
nah still look at pornhub Kanye West
getting real on Jimmy Kimmel Live about
how life hasn't changed much since
having daughters with Kim Kardashian
what kind of stuff do you look at what
category lacked is much favorite what's
the point of being Kanye West if you
can't let's break down black on white
obviously o your own situate my own
reality yes while Kanye wasn't dishing
on his porn preference he did keep it PG
when discussing 5 year old daughter
North's interests in fashion my daughter
went to a fashion camp for 5 days a
couple weeks ago and I visited her
visited her and we put together we put
the thread through the sewing machine
and it really brought me to tears to
think about the 15 years that I've been
working on apparel and my daughter asked
me daddy do you have a sewing machine
sewing machine like this at your office
and I brought her to my office and she
did a bunch of sketches and my head
pattern cutter made her dresses right
there real for her so she loves coming
to the office and doing sketches boy
that's so much more fun than my dad's
office
[Music]
[Applause]